all right joining us now with more facts
without fear the US Surgeon General dr.
Jerome Adams okay why have we had such
good evening Sean
thank you surfer wait I don't your
working day and night I know nobody's
sleeping why is there been so much
confusion on the issue of surgical masks
well that's a great question and it's
important for the American people to
know that the task force always makes
recommendations based on the science and
the science that originally told us that
people who wear masks are not protecting
themselves from the virus we actually
recommend that people who have symptoms
or people who think they may have a
disease to wear a mask so they don't
spread it to others and the w-h-o the
CDC in my office all initially stated
that what's changed
well what's changed is we found that
there are a significant number of people
who have a symptomatic spread of the
virus and so the CDC changed its
recommendations today and they now
suggest that the general public consider
wearing masks when they're going out in
public so as not to spread disease to
other people particularly in situations
where they may be closer than six feet
from each other a couple of really
important points that I want you to know
number one this does not replace social
distancing the most important thing to
do is still the stay home if you're
gonna wear a facial covering please make
sure you don't touch your face and that
you wash your hands so you aren't
contaminating yourself and leave the n95
in the surgical mask to the healthcare
professionals because they need them to
take care of high-risk patients a cloth
facial covering is what the CDC
recommends that works just fine to
protect other people from you because
we're all in this together you wear a
mask to protect me and I wear it to
protect you Sean
didn't you tell Americans tonight that
we have enough mass that will have
enough ventilators do we I mean these
are important questions and I know we've
been getting the daily briefings we know
what GM is doing we know that the
defense hack was utilized by the
president for ventilators and now today
as it relates to 3m but I think what
everybody wants to know like New York
3,000 cases where I live tonight new
cases today and Americans just want to
know that the equipment is going to be
there for frontline workers those and
that put themselves on the line and
want to know that those that get really
sick we'll have the ventilators if they
need them and how important would it be
to get enough hydroxychloroquine to New
York so that Andrew Cuomo's executive
order forcing people into hospitals when
people in consultation with their
doctors want to take it won't have to go
to a hospital which is not necessarily
the best place to be well you asked a
great question about supplies and we are
working number one with the stockpile to
make sure a places like New York City
are getting what they need when they
need it that's not to say that you're
gonna get 30,000 ventilators that's
going to say that's to say if you need
200 ventilators tomorrow we're gonna
make sure you get 200 ventilators
tomorrow so everyone has a ventilator
well the president's also working on the
supply chain and using the defense
production act to create new supplies
we're working on reallocating supplies
locally but the most important thing for
people to know is the way to not run out
of ventilators is to make sure so many
people don't need ventilators and that's
why we extended the the guidelines for
another 30 days we need to drive down
demand or I need not so many people out
there spreading the disease on each
other so that we don't run out of
supplies
I have dr. oz on my radio and TV show
we've talked a lot about
hydroxychloroquine you've been reading
about it what are your thoughts well I
think that there's promising data out
there and dr. oz and I talked dr. Torres
dr. Gupta we talk all the time along
with other people on the task force and
there is some promising data out there
we also want to take back data to make
sure there's the Surgeon General if you
have you contracted this would you take
it well if I contracted it I wouldn't
necessarily take it right away I would
talk to my doctor I have risk factors
and many people know that I've talked
about the fact that I'm pre-diabetic and
I have a lung disease I would talk to my
doctor and determine whether or not we
felt my course with such that I was
someone who should take that but I think
every patient should have the
opportunity to talk to their doctor
about this and make a decision that's
right for them since it's still an
experimental drug at this point all
right at least for this you know every
that's a good point everybody has their
own underlying issues and consulting
your doctor is key on that all right
thank you we hope we can get the
equipment that we
need at the time we needed thank you sir
for all you're doing